CHET HAASE: Hi.
I'm Chet Haase, an engineer on
the Android team at Google.
Today I'm going to show a demo
that's a little bit more about
motivating some of the
techniques I've talked about
in previous DevBytes episodes.
I'll walk through some code, but
it's going to be a pretty
blistering pace because
frankly, a lot of the
techniques in the code are ones
that we've already talked
about on the show.
What I wanted to do with this
application is instead
motivate some of the techniques
that I've talked
about, specifically around
cartoon animation.
So it's a little bit hard when
you click on a button and you
see it fall down to the bottom
of the screen and squish at
the bottom, to understand why
you would want to do that in
your application.
And frankly, most applications
probably
shouldn't do that maybe.
It would be a little disturbing
or silly.
But there are some applications
that really want
to be more engaging
to the user.
And it's worth understanding a
type of application that might
want to use that to be more
playful and engaging in
general, more interactive
with the user.
I wanted to show how to use some
of these techniques that
we've talked about in previous
episodes, as well as in the
talk at Google I/O 2013 called
"A Moving Experience," to show
how you want to use some of
these cartoon animation
techniques, and put them all
together in some larger
example to give that more
engaging feeling to the user.
We're going to be showing things
about anticipation,
about overshoot, about
exaggeration, and in general,
just being a little bit more
fun, engaging, and playful.
So let's take a look
at the demo.
Here we go.
We get into the application, and
we've got this button that
is bouncing.
It's ready to go.
It wants us to engage.
Even though we're not
interacting with the
application, that's not a reason
why the application
can't be interacting with us.
It's trying to attract our
attention here, and then
eventually we'll fall for it.
We'll press on the button.
This is a technique that we
showed in some earlier
episodes about anticipation,
where when we click on the
button, maybe it doesn't just
have to change color.
Maybe it can actually physically
interact with the
user, and actually press
in or press out.
To show that there's a physical
interaction with the
button actually going down as
the user presses on it.
So we press the button
and then when we
let go, watch carefully.
It's going to launch out and
then just keep going.
It launches out toward
the user.
And then we get into this
other activity.
And this is actually a
separate activity.
Again, this is a technique I
talked about in a previous
episode about custom activity
animations.
We're not running a window
animation here, which has a
standard way of running where
things scale and fade in.
Instead, we're disabling that,
and we're running a custom
activity animation by
automatically launching the
sub activity with a
white background.
So it's fully opaque, but it's
the same opaque background as
the one we came from.
But first, we basically animate
the stuff to get out
of the way, and then the sub
activity launches with that
same plain white background.
And then the contents in
that activity animate.
They scale in.
So we have this continuous
motion from the previous
activity launching, fading, and
going past the user, and
then the new content
coming in with this
custom activity animation.
Now we're on the first screen
here, and we have some things
that look vaguely like buttons
down at the bottom.
And did you notice that
they popped in?
Everything here is about being
more interactive and playful
and alive, in general.
We can click on one of these.
We can say, OK-- and it's
very simple too, right?
It's just asking
for your name.
Not a lot going on here.
Maybe the game is intended
for kids, right?
So you want to make
it as simple and
streamlined as possible.
So we say, yep.
I'm going to play--
I'm the returning player
called Pat.
OK, what difficulty
are going to play?
I am awesome at this game, I'm
going to be mega hard.
Now, notice when I press on the
buttons again it's that
same interactive thing.
I press on the button, the
button actually goes into the
screen, away from the user.
And then comes back out, it
springs and overshoots,
showing that interactive model
of engaging the user through
actually interacting through
the physical presses and
releases on the screen.
As I release the button, you're
going to see the same
thing you did on the previous
screen, which is the button is
going to launch out at the user
and then animate into
place at the top
of the screen.
You notice another element on
all these screens is the text
is going to animate out.
We have this flow of the
application going
from right to left.
And we do this with a little
bit of anticipation on the
text, again, a technique that
we saw on a previous demo.
Where the text will actually
skew to the right and then
shift to the left.
This is like traditional cartoon
animations where
someone's going to run.
But before they run, they're
going to rear
back and get ready.
Which really helps the user
understand exactly what's
about to happen.
Not just during the action, but
actually before the action.
We anticipate the text.
It's going to anticipate
the animation.
And then it's going to shift
quickly off the screen.
And then finally, of course,
you want to ask for the
child's credit card number.
Because that's where the
real money is, right?
That's it.
We can step through it again.
You see the button.
You see the engaging,
playful thing.
You launch into the
sub activity here,
pressing the buttons.
The buttons are interacting,
the text is giving all this
playful stuff.
Let's take a very quick
look at the code.
There's a lot of code here.
But again, the techniques are
similar to techniques that we
saw in these previous
DevBytes episodes.
So it's not worth belaboring
these too much.
We have Toon Game.
This is the main activity.
We're listening for touches
on the button.
And when we get one, we're going
to animate the scale so
the button scales into the
screen away from the user.
And when they release, we're
going to trap that here, and
we're going to animate back to
the regular scale thing.
But then we're also going to
perform the click operation,
which is going to go into
the subactivity.
That is down here.
When we play, we're
going to animate.
We're going to keep scaling
the button out
from where it was.
It's going to scale, and it's
also going to fade out at the
same time and come out
toward the user.
And then when it's done, we're
going to launch the sub
activity, this new intent.
We're going to start
the activity.
We're going to override the
pending transition.
I don't want window
animations here.
I'm already doing my custom
activity animation.
You get the window animations
out of the way with overriding
pending transitions with zero.
And then it launches the sub
activity, which is this
PlayerSetupActiviy here.
Player Setup Activity has
various elements.
A lot of code in here,
not worth going into.
Again, same techniques all
over the place in here.
We have the button
press listeners.
When you click on one of
these things, it's
going to scale in.
When you release, it's
going to scale back
out to where it was.
And then when a button is
clicked, it's going to animate
into place up at the
top of the screen.
I didn't simply want to pop that
view out from where it
was because the layout would
have been affected by that.
Instead, I'm going to set that
invisible ability there in its
previous state.
And then I'm going to create
a copy of that button and
animate that in a parent
container.
As I move that in this virtual
curve, scaling out and then
scaling back down into place at
the top of the screen where
it's going to live.
Then the text skewing
animation--
again, we've seen this
in previous demos.
That happens in this custom
text view sub class I have
here, called skewable
text view.
We're going to animate the skew
property of the text as
it skews to the right and then
shifts over to the left.
And that happens by simply
animating the skew value,
invalidating appropriately,
also invalidate the parent
around the area of the skew.
So we actually erase and redraw
the appropriate area.
And that's the utility method
for doing that.
And that's about it.
There's a lot of code in here.
But again, we went over the
actual techniques of the code
in detail in the previous
DevBytes episodes.
So be sure to check those out,
as well as the code for this
application.
It should be available at a link
on this YouTube video.
Thanks.